welcome to Startalk chat room this is a
deep dive into the cosmos and we're
featuring episodes 7 & 8 from cosmos
possible worlds and later we'll be
joined by planetary scientist Carolyn
Porco to talk about Cassini at Saturn
but right now let's get into episode 7
titled the search for intelligent life
on Earth so this this this episode opens
with a shot of the current world's
largest Observatory it's 500 meters in
diameter it's called it's called the fat
Chuck hey Chuck hey how's it going
see this is Startalk in the corona verse
that's right you do this well how did
you it's called the fast telescope which
is a brilliant acronym so it's 500 meter
aperture spherical telescope and it's in
China and we'll tell you more about it
in just a minute but to get images for
it it's so large you can't just take a
handheld camera and photograph it so we
had these drones that just ascended
right up the middle of it and then the
whole telescope comes into view it's so
large it's a mile in circumference Wow
yeah it's just it's just crazy that is
mind-blowing
yeah and it's large because for several
reasons
radio waves themselves are large and
it's a radio wave telescope so radio
waves can be anywhere from a few
centimeters small radio waves right in
fact they're micro waves that's weeks
yes there you go short end of radio
waves are called micro waves and then
just got longer and longer and longer so
this telescope can receive radio waves
from the universe and then focus them so
you have to be big just to receive big
waves but also radio waves don't carry
much energy so you want as much of a
collecting area as possible to get as
much of that signal whatever it is and
wherever it's coming from in the
universe so that you can take it decode
it and figure out what the hell's going
on
and what's interesting about radio waves
is they passed through obscuring dust
and gas in the galaxy uh-huh so many the
pre pictures you see from Hubble they're
beautiful because parts of it are
blocking views from behind or they're
glowing red or green or yellow or blue
and so it's very beautiful but it's
obscuring your your vistas to the rest
of the universe
radio waves passed right through that so
radio waves pass through these obscuring
these things that would otherwise
obscure our view of the gallic of the
universe exactly so if you're aliens and
they have technologies such as we and
they're smart such as we or at least we
define ourselves as being smart then
they would figure out as we have that
radio waves would be ideal modes of
communication across the galaxy with
what would be other alien life right
because you don't want it stopping in
some gas cloud what does that
right-waist so unless unless there's a
life-form that lives in the gas cloud
yeah but okay so then you wouldn't need
radio waves you can use some other form
light just together let's stop at them
in the gas cloud and so so other bands
of light just don't have this ability to
penetrate the clouds the way radio waves
do so
radio waves become a very efficient
means of sending signals and receiving
signals if you're going to search for
extraterrestrial life now that when you
look at our SETI array of all these you
know dishes setting so the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence right yes
so as is it most likely that if we
receive communication that it will
indeed be through radio waves I'm just
saying if they want to talk across the
galaxy that's the best way to do it
unless
they figured out yet here's what it's a
little scary you know we only discovered
radio waves you know hundred twenty
years ago hundred three hundred Hertz
and a few others in the late 19th
century so if you if if someone sent
signals to earth during the Roman Empire
way there's still what we would call
intelligence on earth but have no clue
that someone was trying to Yap at them
from across the galaxy so imagine that
there's some other means of
communicating we have yet to discover
that's even better than anything we've
invented but the aliens have figured
that out Wow they could be yapping at us
right now and Olivia's it's funny
because it's what you say makes so much
sense in that I'm just picturing an
ancient Roman with a radio right now
just twist in the DAO going there is
nothing on this thing I mean yeah well
it's right so so who are we to say that
radio waves is the be-all and end-all of
how you would communicate through the
galaxy I could have come up with
something as advanced compared to our
radio waves as radio waves are compared
to Romans just screaming at each other
across the countryside so could you
so radio waves I mean are they superior
or just different than light or
different spectrums of light that's a
great question so we know the rainbow
red orange yellow green blue indigo
violet ROYGBIV if you want a way to
remember that and we used to think
that's just everything and that's it
that and then you find out know there's
like infrared on the other side and you
keep going and you keep making the
wavelengths a little longer you get to
infrared then you get to microwaves you
get to radio waves how about on the
other side with the violet you can make
wavelength shorter
go from violet to ultraviolet and then
you go to x-rays and then gamma rays
these are the words we have to describe
the entire electromagnetic spectrum all
of it is quote radiation of different
wavelengths radiation has gotten a bad
rap in in common
carlins we think of it as whatever is
bad for you right I get that I
understand that but speaking physically
about this all of these waves are some
form of radiation and only some
varieties of it are damaging to you
so x-rays you know you don't want to be
around x-rays too much not too much okay
you know I figured this out when I was a
kid right I'd be there in the dentist
right and they're ready to take an x-ray
and what does the x-ray technician do
just before they take x-ray they leave
the room beep sir it's like oh you're
totally safe I'm just gonna go over here
what so why is this okay thing all right
I remember thinking this when I was like
9 years old
why is she behind a blast shield if I'm
getting zapped I remembered thinking
that all right so yeah x-rays in low
dose or can be very beneficial to
diagnosing your health and your your
your particularly if you have you know
broken bones
gamma rays have other consequences they
get in and start messing with your DNA
okay who's the most famous gamma ray the
Hulk the Hulk of course yeah so so we
have evidence from DC Comics that
excessive gamma exposure turns you into
the Hulk but only when you get angry
only when you get mad right exactly and
honestly seriously he just needed a
therapist bro you got anger issues you
got anger issues bro he needs a
therapist all right and we can work this
thing out you know what my another
favorite there's a meme out there called
the credible Hulk have you ever seen
that no but that sounds great Incredible
Hulk if you don't want me to be angry
you don't like it you won't like it when
I'm angry because if you don't give me
proper evidence peer-reviewed research
angry I like that
[Laughter]
so any out so there you have it and so
this Chinese telescope we used to have
the largest in the world in utter SIBO
Puerto Rico and that was the largest
like four decades meant for 50 years
that was the largest telescope in the
world and so now the single largest is
in China so Chuck let's get to my
interview with Jason Clark one of the
executive producers of cosmos possible
world he became a good friend he was
executive producer from 2014 as well as
a spacetime Odyssey he has some
interesting films in his portfolio by
the way he did Stuart Little
really yeah and he did I was the one
with the talking dog mr. Peabody yeah so
he's uh he's it's got quite the only
inviting yeah so he I so I asked him
what was his favorite scene in all of
cosmos and guess where that took us
there's a great scene one of my
favorites I would say is when you go to
China - world's largest radio telescope
yeah and it's I don't remember but I
think it's a half a kilometer across
what's a mile in circumference yeah a
good way for Americans to think about is
he was largest in the world and and the
previous largest one which was in a merc
yeah I used to have a baby we don't have
the biggest one
what are we go yes they're at Arecibo
Puerto Rico that is so what it means is
if there's a alien message in the din of
cosmic noise the most powerful
telescopes in the world may pick it up
if they do it'll be the Chinese
telescope first oh wow the first
scientist they will encounter will be
Chinese so have there ever been these
moments where you've actually believed
maybe that's a real signal I'm not
authorized to oh that's it turn off the
cameras
no but that but that scene was a that
was in an attempt to convey to the
viewer here we are
either listening for signals or maybe
even sending signals for intelligent
life yet there's stuff going on
underfoot yeah some of them backyard
so this planet which is you know what's
most people take for granted it's what
we've grown up on its while we've known
but at the same time there's so much
going on in a way that we're not aware
of whether that's you know bees and how
they live the bee story that's another
edible story the disease we you know
you're a busy bee usually means you're
busy doing nothing you just move you
just you know move an air around and
there they are and I learned a lot too
I'm an astrophysicist but I don't carry
expertise in every topic that I
discussed that was scripted and reviewed
by other scientists yeah where it's
their expertise yeah so that's another
sort of unique aspect of this the the
scientific intersection that again the
EP would look over that right yeah so we
you know you know each episode we sent
the script to a series of experts that
we had hired and each episode was picked
apart because not only do you want this
kind of what's the new thought and idea
but you want one that's been proven or
vetted scientifically enough that it's
worth repeating right because some ideas
are are so early in their discovery that
they haven't gone through them well an
important element that and persistently
introduces which enables the
storytelling at the level that it is is
we will distinguish between established
science and science that's just on the
edge yeah and so if it is this then this
could be true so we're very honest yet
scripturally honest yes literally
Scriptures the scriptures are honest
script Tuohy
honest about the science that is
speculative versus the science that's
established yeah I find that to be you
know there's there's so much detail it's
very rich this season and there's so
many stories and going back
to the radio telescope the idea that the
natural world that surrounds us has so
many stories that have yet to been told
to be told that may teach us about how
life could exist elsewhere oh wow man so
that first of all fascinating stuff and
more importantly what the hell is up
with America okay what is going on
alright seriously seriously what is up
okay the whole point of the episode was
to use that as an excuse to say here we
might be using telescopes such as this
to send signals to potential aliens or
vice-versa to receive them but when in
fact we have evidence of intelligence on
earth that we've overlooked for not only
centuries but millennia and so right
there in episode 7 we introduced to you
perhaps for the first time the
intelligence of bees sweet now you know
there's no pun intended now you know
there be lovers out there who think of
bees as producers of honey and of course
the vegans don't eat the honey right and
so bees
honestly vegans it's bee vomit you can't
come on seriously you can't bring
yourself to eat the bee vomit it's not
like you're hurting the bees no you're
missing the opportunity a bee bars just
to beep yeah beep are there you go bee
barf it's like come on I got it I got a
feeling the bees are feeling just a
little superior every time we eat a
little honey there's just like can you
believe those humans scarf scarfing down
our barf scarfing our barfing really so
I first person I heard call addy barf
was David brennick the comedian oh
that's right Philadelphia comic David
Brenner yeah yeah he I turned say that I
think what he's hosting Johnny Carson
this was now 800 years ago I was about
the same who's Johnny Carson but but in
there we names two hosts ago from Jimmy
Fallon of the time
so so we explore bees and and I didn't
this stuff I didn't know as I made clear
in that interview right that bees when
they're at in the hive and they're just
sort of there's a waggle dance that they
do where they flap their wings and and
shake their butts yeah and the jiggle
their their abdomen and they're
communicating with each other not only
distance but azimuth and and you know
they're giving coordinates again where
they just came from yes
and so it's three coordinates if you
want to know something in
three-dimensional space you need three
coordinates so you need in this case
would be azimuth altitude and distance
that would uniquely get you to a place
they are communicating this and as far
as we can tell we can justifiably say
these are using abstract symbolism to
communicate information and that's what
mathematics is Wow so this is cosmos at
its best where it just gets a cosmic
perspective in this case a an
earth-based biological perspective on
what you always thought you in your
relationship to the world around you
mm-hmm that's uh I gotta tell you that's
it's actually um somewhat elegant and
poetic no I agree I agree yeah now Chuck
you didn't I'm surprised dating cue in
on the fact that I did not answer his
question whether we've received signals
from aliens yeah I I know you said I'm
not authorized and he kind of let that
go yeah yeah but so [__] but here's that
here's why I didn't again but see here's
why I didn't I let it go because I've
actually been with you in your office
and eavesdropping while you were on the
phone with somebody from the Department
of Defense and I was like you know what
this ain't none of my business I only
know drones coming over my house I'm not
even gonna ask him what that was about
I'm like I'm not even gonna ask what
that was about is none of my damn bit
man yo bismillah Road hovering outside
your engine window that's all I'm saying
here's my point
the we somehow believe that the
government is some all-knowing
all-powerful entity where if aliens were
communicating with earth that somehow
only the government would receive the
signal right well the government doesn't
have the biggest telescopes in the world
astronomers do and we're not part of the
government we're a network of folks and
we communicate with each other all the
time we share data and there's a scene
in the movie contact with the Jodie
Foster character is receiving signals
from aliens and the government comes in
we're gonna shut this down is it and she
said no not until I send out this email
she said - who - everyone right they got
a signal just to the US military it's a
signal to everybody yeah well and you
know I mean somebody like you probably
has to say that here's here's my final
thought before we go on to our next half
of this segment with Carolyn Porco
okay good friend and colleague here's a
question that I just live with okay we
say let's look for intelligent life in
the universe that's what the eye is in
SETI the search for extraterrestrial
extraterrestrial intelligence all right
that presupposes that we are the measure
of the intelligence we're looking for
okay
well get a species that's slightly more
intelligent than we are okay okay
would they a judge us to be intelligent
and even if so or not would they be able
to communicate with us so for example
you can rank quote below humans other
intelligent life forms on Earth so
dolphins elephants big brained mammals
they're chimpanzees are we having a
conversation with any of them are you
sitting down with the chimp you see well
what do you feel about the state of the
world today no no we have not had any
meaningful conversation with any other
life form that we would consider
intelligent that's slightly less
intelligent than we are
why believe that some other life form
slightly more intelligent than us could
sit down and have any kind of meaningful
conversation with us
that's the skepticism with which I
approach this search so really we could
be Joey from friends looking for Jim
Carrey and Dumb and Dumber and aliens
and aliens are just like look at these
idiots and there's no way there's no
reason to talk to them no it could no no
I can do one better than that okay
Stephen Hawking telephoning Albert
Einstein and the aliens will say these
idiots that is too fun oh my god so oh
man that's so crazy think about this yes
it's like two of the smartest people in
our human existence
yes ever and they're talking to one
another and the aliens here two babies
just going oh my god that's scary it's
well we got thrown a commercial from
dark talk chat room deep dive into the
cosmos when we come back we'll explore
episode eight with a guest on the show
Carolyn Porco a friend and colleague and
she was head of the imaging team at the
Cassini spacecraft ascend
we're back from break Startalk deep dive
now we're gonna talk about episode 8 of
cosmos possible herbs titled the
sacrifice of Cassini sounds biblical
doesn't that check first of all it's a
great episode secondly I will never
forgive you for making me feel sorry for
an inanimate thing so I was so sad I was
so sad for Cassini I was like oh my god
Chuck and you either had nothing to do
with it let's bring someone on who did
the exact and you had a real access to
emotion all right let me bring on
Carolyn Porco
she's a friend a colleague of weird
about the same station in life
professionally so we've known each other
like since graduate school Cara
how you doing Carolyn I'm doing great
I'm actually doing great excellent
and and I've always called you madam
Saturn yeah that was with deep affection
were you okay with that I love it Neil I
really love it I have to thank you for
it okay one of the best nicknames I've
ever had I had I had older brothers so
you could imagine all the nicknames I
had that you look great in the episode
for those who haven't seen it
Carolyn is in it oh yes thank you
and you you've been a longtime friend of
Startalk I just want to thank you for
that you've been there for us many times
and for those that don't know or don't
remember you are a leader the Cassini
imaging science team and just give us a
note of what that means because people
that I think they think of a spacecraft
if just maybe just one antenna or
something they don't know the full sort
of getup of what these things are the
Cassini spacecraft carried something
like 12 investigations and one of them
was a camera system which really meant
there were two telescopes
instruments instruments and so the
Cassini instruments set were two
telescopes we call them cameras and they
operated mostly in the visible portion
of the spectrum so they basically saw
what our eye see we went a little bit
into the ultraviolet a little bit into
the near-infrared but it was basically
the extension of our senses they produce
the highest resolution images that were
taken by Cassini and so the scientific
objectives that the imaging team my
science team members and I wanted to do
were very broad in scope they covered
everything you could see from the
atmosphere of Saturn the atmosphere of
Titan the surfaces of the satellites and
also their orbits determining their
orbits I just want to emphasize because
your detector was slightly better than
our eyes in the spectral range but it
was basically seeing what we would see
if we were strapped to the spacecraft
yes exactly that's what a minute saying
they're like an extension of our
eyesight do I want to say though that
you're where our eyes are much better
photo metrically than our cameras were
but that's another story too so anyway
we our science objectives were very
broad and our priorities and science
anyway were to pick up where Voyager
left off and so we wanted to make sure
that we could see down to the surface of
Titan because Voyager never saw the
surface of Titan we wanted to look for
Titan one of Saturn's moons
one of Saturn's moons its largest moons
with a very thick hefty atmosphere and
we wanted to check out whether Enceladus
had plumes coming off its surface
because that was one of the ideas that
were that was on our brains when we put
Cassini together one was the e ring of
Saturn created by the plume coming off
in selling us and then we the only ring
in the Pentagon last I checked so now we
have a neat ring around Saturn oh yeah
the way the Pentagon is just as designed
there's five rings aren't there so
anyway we wanted to do a lot of
scientific things
and so it was very big very big job and
we did all that we saw down to the
surface of Titan and we were the ones
who first saw the lakes and the largest
sea on Titan we found the plume and the
geyser is coming off in celle dhis we
found new moons new rings new phenomena
we saw mind-blowing details and just
incredible things that we even things we
did not expect to see in the rings of
Saturn so it was just it was an
amazingly productive mission
scientifically so the moon I just say my
my other priority was to make sure that
we presented our results in the most
inspirational and clear manner possible
and and I really wanted very much to
make the rest of the world feel like
they were riding along with us by just
making our images gorgeous so that was
another very high priority ok so but
this didn't come from nowhere because
reading your resume you had some
significant overlap with the voyage of
the very Voyager mission that you're
saying this is the next best set of
images that we would get of Saturn
Voyager launched in the 1970s how old
could you have been back then so I think
what you're getting at is for you want
me to say that I was part of the Voyager
mission I think that's why I think I got
that on your resume is that right yeah
yes yes and and believe me that was like
the best thing that ever happened to me
I feel like I've led I've said this a
thousand times I've led a charmed
existence and being being part of the
imaging team on Voyager was was just
colossal II good but I I did my thesis
on Voyager data of Saturn's rings and
then by the time I graduated graduate
school I was added to the imaging team
and helped plan the yeren his fly by in
the Neptune flyby so that's why I
thought I don't know why actually but I
thought I hell I'll leave that
steam going to Saturn and that's that
happen well if you have the pedigree
coming in then you do you become the
obvious choice I guess so I don't know
but let me add to that in Voyager of
course Carl Sagan was very active with
Voyager so and I remember how much care
he invested in communicating the results
of Voyager to everybody and not only
with his sort of fireside manner but he
was on Johnny Carson The Tonight Show
doing so and scientists never were on
The Tonight Show so did any of that kind
of legacy spill over into you for you to
say standing there flat-footed that when
you're taking these images of Saturn's
worth Cassini you want to make sure
they're they come across to the public
in the most inspirational way where did
that come from well okay so I cannot
deny that Carl was a big influence and
you know everybody in our generation
loved him I cannot say the same for his
colleagues who quite resented and some
would look down on him for what they
called grandstanding just to be clear
our generation is slightly about a half
generation younger than Carl Sagan so we
were not sort of competing faculty and
we were studiously on the rise we were
students on the rise we're actually one
Jenner he's 20 years older generation so
so anyway you know he was just very
inspirational to me but you know my
desire to do the images in present them
in a beautiful way actually goes back to
the fact that I don't know if we have
time to talk about this but if I'll just
riff and you pull out of this anything
you want it goes back to the fact that
on Voyager the images were processed in
you know red green blue color and all
that only for the press conferences I
mean that had never been done before
that people actually put images together
just to get the public excited the
public didn't matter to all the the
mission people that came before Voyager
and came before Carl so I
saw that they did this just for the
press releases and they they weren't the
best they weren't what they really could
have been and in fact there was a member
of the press corps he was an amateur
astronomer as name was Andrew Young and
he criticized the Voyager imaging team
for not doing a better job at making the
images more presentable so I'm a young
scientist yeah at really standing up at
press conferences saying you guys really
you're falling down on the job here and
I made it I made a big mental note of
that and I when I became the team leader
I thought check I'm gonna do that I'm
gonna make sure they really look good so
that was also a motive for me to do it
and and you know because you do this -
Neal you just you know you want to share
it's just the joy of sharing knowledge
and how much better to convey the
knowledge that we're finding than to
have an image people really connect with
images it's you know it's that link
between our visual field and our cortex
and you know the images like get right
in there is a hook so I mean it's
amazing that here you say this now I
shouldn't say amazing it's it's very
cool to hear you say this now because in
97 when you guys are launching we were
not living in the age of the image which
is where we are now yes so you know here
we have Facebook and Instagram and you
know the Internet and we live in an
image driven culture right now and so
you are literally I would say 17 or 18
years literally ahead of your time
that's no that's got to feel good well
it does it feels very good but
understand what made that the era of the
image happen is the Internet in Voyager
days when we were sharing images we
weren't sharing images over the internet
because there wasn't people were mailing
hardcopy images to each other wait are
the three of us on rocking chairs on a
porch right now
I don't know I have to say sometimes I
feel that way Carolyn how's your
rheumatism I think my knees tells me is
gonna rain tomorrow so Carolyn I think
one of the more memorable images
memorable for it's not so much for how
spectacular look but for what it
contained
was the pale blue dot and could you give
us a moment about what what you remember
about the pale blue dot back under
Voyager and what was your attempt to
reprise that with Cassini okay so I
think as you said and it's clear the
image itself wasn't the most spectacular
and it was but but it was a fabulous
idea and I often say this I know maybe
it sounds I don't know what it sounds
like but I'm proud of the fact that I
came up with the idea independently of
Carl we were both trying to work it
through the JPL Voyager project he was
three years I think before I was but Jeb
propulsion labs in Pasadena California
yes that was that was Basecamp for
Voyager is that correct that was that
was the days when the conduct of a
mission was entirely centralized at the
at the NASA center in this case it was
JPL that didn't happen on Cassini but on
at JPL everything happened that you on
Voyager everything happened at JPL and
just just a just to catch people up the
pale blue dot is an image of Earth taken
by Voyager went after Voyager past
Neptune looking back towards the inner
solar system and then you see this small
dot barely filling a few pixels not just
a pixel okay I think it was just a pixel
but it was a small little dot okay and
so I'll tell you since we were talking
about heart well anyway so Carl had this
group of people helping him at JPL I
didn't know about it
I was also trying to get it done then in
1988 this is seven years after Carl or
six or seven years after Carl had
started to try to get the picture taken
but the project didn't want to do it
because they didn't want to spend
resources and I - and my attempts kept
hearing the refrain why do you want to
go through all that trouble just to take
a picture of something that's gonna be a
pixel no one copped on to it no one got
it
Carl kept pushing it with his his small
group of advocates and then in 88 I
found out that he was doing that I said
hey I've been trying to do it too and we
joined forces and I ended up being the
person who computed the exposure times
okay so I did have in the end have
something had something to do with his
his version of the project so but what
I'll tell you I'll tell you let me just
say this because this is germane of what
we were saying before when the picture
got finally taken and Brad Smith leader
of the employed imaging team his office
is at University of Arizona is like
three hours down from mine he calls me
into his offices come in I got to show
you something and he hands me the
picture and it's black and a few streaks
of light on it and my first impulse to
take my hand and wipe the dust off it
and one of the pieces of dust I wanted a
wipe away was the earth and bread and
Brad says exactly meaning yes it's only
the size of a piece of dust so the
picture itself I don't know if the
picture would have had as profound and
effect as it has had over time if it
weren't for Carl who who layered meaning
on it and made it clear what it
signified and it ended up signifying a
call to all of us to regard ourselves as
one tribe and to put the safeguarding of
the health of our biosphere and our and
our environment to make them of
paramount importance in decisions that
we make and managing our existence on
the planet and and that's why overall
these years it's become a powerful meme
has it not pale blue dot you say pale
blue dot it immediately signifies you
know the smallness of Earth we're all in
this together and this is all we gotten
we better protect it and it's all down
to Karl he's the one who made that
happen
now you reprise this at Saturn right
this is my pager I must have shown to
the public a thousand times I and thank
you cuz I love that picture and I'm glad
you're letting other people enjoy this
is Saturn in the foreground beautifully
illuminated and there's this dot in the
background and you zoom in I say whoa
that's Earth so it's kind of like a pale
blue dot for our next generation yes and
it had a twist so here's the thing you
know once you do something like you show
people a new perspective you open the
door to people and they see something
they've never seen before they see
themselves as they've never seen
themselves before it kind of gives them
a new self-image it redefines themselves
and once you do that you can't really
have that same impact again it's why
lots of missions have taken pale blue
dots from the surface of Mars from on
the way to Jupiter I mean lots of
spacecraft have done this they don't
have the same effect right so so then
correct me if I'm wrong was that the
image you took when you had everyone
look out up at Saturn and smile yes
that's what I was getting at oh that's
that's that's what I was getting at that
I added this twist where I thought it
would be it would be great
well this occurred to me while I was
planning it it would be great to just
invite people of the world ahead of time
let them know ahead of time that your
picture is gonna be taken from a billion
miles away go out look up you know think
about your existence think about where
you are I think about the uniqueness of
our planet and just smile at the sheer
joy of being alive on a pale blue dot
and people all over the world did that
it was so it was just it was great it
was actually
up at Saturn from Earth while you were
exposing the image yes that was the
directive at this that this time this is
when the picture-taking window opens go
out and of course I didn't want to leave
out half the planet because only half
the planet could see Saturn so it was
for me it was just you know use the
moment to to appreciate the magnificence
of what's happening and smile just smile
at the universe smile at being a part of
it all you know it's a beautiful
connecting moment though it's really
cool
I you know you would have thought that I
being just I was the person who started
it I didn't think had been thinking
about it for three years by the time it
happened when it when I was there at
that moment I was being interviewed by
the BBC I got as into it as I was hoping
everybody else would it was such a rush
it really was a rush it made the solar
system feel like a very much smaller
place you know it was it was great so
let's get on to the to the sacrifice of
Cassini yeah all know have you seen the
episode there came a time when Cassini's
mission was over and we didn't want it
to accidentally slam into a moon that we
might want to investigate in the future
for the possibility of life because it
could be microbes stowaway microbes on
Cassini so we plunked it down into
Saturn so let me ask you suppose someone
handed you some extension money for
Cassini said okay you have another five
years what would you do with Cassini if
you had another five-year stay of
execution
the governor says no kids exactly you
will be surprised but I personally would
do nothing because we we had that whole
thing planned so well that by the time
we sent it on its way the fuel was being
exhausted a lot of the instruments were
starting to degrade we had squeezed
every delicious bit we could out of that
and I would have said at that time if
someone said five more years I would
have said we should take the resources
that would be spent here and put them to
the next mission which could be better
equipped to follow on from Cassini like
we followed on from Voyager and now as
the questions that Cassini has left
behind and you couldn't do that with the
Cassini instruments so then that begs
the question what is the next mission
well that's being debated you know these
things are always very hotly contested
they're people who want to go to you
know you rope up I just want to
interject here that it was highly
enlightened of you to say to yourself
and to others
Cassini's useful time is done we could
hang on to it but there are other
missions and this money would be kept
here instead of going to other missions
that can extend this this question of
discovery exactly so I just want to
congratulate you for that level of
insight and foresight for how science
works okay thank you but no one ever
asks me
so next mission so what would we do you
know to me I mean you might get
different answers from different
scientists but for me the most thrilling
question that we have in planetary
exploration before us is whether or not
there are organisms on other planets the
the real the real Holy Grail would be if
we could find that life had originated
independently of Earth I don't know that
we'd be able to prove that a hundred
percent because there's material that
exchanges back and forth but when you
get to the outer solar system like
Saturn there just to be clear so people
know what you mean in the solar system
you can have sort of asteroid impacts on
one planet that can cast rocks into
space that then land on other planets so
there's an exchange of material that's
been going on for billions of years and
it's happened a lot between Earth and
Mars mm-hmm right we have Martian
meteorites here that were delivered that
way
people have done calculations what are
the chances that something from Earth or
Mars could have gotten out to Saturn and
landed on Enceladus or landed on Europa
on Jupiter and so on so when you say
microbes on other planets I presume you
mean on the moons of other planets I'm
sorry I mean on the moons of other
planet right right yes and if so this is
one of your babies right did wasn't
Enceladus one of your research interests
well I started out as a ring scientist
and doing work in planetary rings but
when we found what we found that
Enceladus I was so blown away I thought
this is a place because we figured out
right away that it implied liquid water
and the presence of liquid water we have
since learned that those geysers that
you see and those beautiful spectacular
images that liquid water could possibly
be reaching all the way to the surface
I mean all the way to the surface so it
doesn't really this is often said it's
like a cliche but it doesn't get better
than that when you're thinking about a
habitable zone you want to that could
have life that's what a habitable zone
is and a way to sample it because with
Enceladus the ocean underneath its ice
shell its habitable zone is expressing
itself into space so what you're saying
is I think what you're saying is you
could go to Enceladus and rather than
have to dig through this multi kilometer
thick sheet of ice if there are geysers
carrying water from below to the surface
then any fishes or microbes get carried
with it and then they land on the
surface and so you can go there and find
freeze-dried fish possibly well I have I
think if there was a lot of freeze-dried
fish we might have seen a spectral
signature of them but to be honest I've
never taken a spectrum I don't really
know it so you only know what you're
looking at if you have a lab samples
from back here on earth okay so somebody
watching should go and take a spectrum
of a fish
well Neal's hypothesis but I don't I
don't think we have fish on the surface
you know we're scientists you know we're
rather conservative and boring we'd be
happy with microbes it's not out of the
question that there could be microbes
there on on Enceladus and so it's what
is the process to you fly by and through
a plume collect and return or do you
land I mean what what how do you
envision a mission like that taking
place well funny you should say that
because there's a big activity right now
going on in the planetary science
community where people are discussing
that very thing what can you do with one
type of mission like maybe just a repeat
of Cassini you orbit Saturn and you just
repeatedly go through the plume of
Enceladus once every orbit around Saturn
of course you'd be completely outfitted
on your spacecraft with a completely
different set of instruments so you'd be
much more you could do much more than
Cassini could do but that's a limited
mission there's also the possibility you
could get into orbit around Enceladus
and then you're flying through the plume
every Enceladus orbit which is like an
hour and a half and picking up a lot of
material my favorite of course is
landing on the surface because then all
you got to do since the material the icy
portion of it anyway the the tiny frost
particles go up and 96% of them come
down at the surface all you got to do is
go down open up your collector plates
and let the stuff snow on you and then
ship that stuff off into your various
instruments and there's a lot you can do
there because you're collecting material
all the time so that's almost as good as
a sample return because you already have
the sample and you just put the right
instruments there with your space probe
and you don't need to bring this stuff
back if you can analyze it on the spot
right well that that's true but barren I
mean I'm not a big fan of sample return
because it's very risky it's very it's
very expensive for what you get you
just get like micrograms worth the stuff
when you could have lots more material
by just going there so plus if it's your
mission and it comes back to earth you
don't want it to be responsible for the
the Porco virus that you don't yeah
that's right yeah there's always that
there's planetary protection that's a
big issue but we have to worry about
forward protection if we land on the
surface so that's a that's a big that's
a big thing you have to think about but
we gotta bring this to a close just make
quick forward protection why can't we
just sterilize our spacecraft the
problem is that sterilizing your
spacecraft when some of the instruments
that you want to carry actually involve
bringing organic material with you okay
I mean there's I think they're called
assays where they bring material along
and if you take a bit of the stuff you
captured and you stick it in that little
pod or stick it in that little pot you
examine what happens and that's your
measurement it's the organic soup of
some kind yeah so so it's it's the
techniques you would have to use to
sterilize your spacecraft could could
you know ruin your experiment so it's a
it's gonna be a sensitive balance I
don't know what's being actually what
they're they're thinking about these
days for planetary protection all right
Carolyn it's really as always great
talking with you here and you reflect on
your life and the life of our field and
thanks for joining us for this sort of
recap of cosmos possible world episode
eight well thank you very much for
having me as always it's great to see
you guys again glad you're still kicking
we are still kids are always good to
have you there and you've been watching
possibly listening to Startalk chatroom
a deep dive into the cosmos I've been
your host Neil deGrasse Tyson until next
week we will cover episodes I think nine
of Cosmos possible
[Music]